my name is sebastian cuttes i work at
inwt statistics
we are doing full stack data science
consulting so we consult mostly medium
and large size companies
we do everything from data strategy
consulting to running
data backends or part of data backends
of
data products of com for different
companies
uh the agenda for today will be that i
first introduced a business task at the
neue osneprocatsitung
the project that i'm presenting today
originated from a different project we
had with a larger organization of
newspapers
so there was data available
for uh from the newspapers and
we have a stu we had a student susana
rooker who sadly uh can be here today
who wrote her master thesis
based on these data
and then afterwards we
worked a little bit on it put it into a
white paper for our website and i'm
presenting to you today
the results
after first introducing the business
task
i will talk a little bit about the nlp
methods there were a bunch of a few
talks already at this conference about
it so i will keep it short
then we will get into does the content
really matter what can nlp
bring to the table in analyzing reader
preferences
uh
i will talk a bit about explainable ai
uh
maybe a show of hands who was at the xai
meets nlp talk
30 minutes ago okay if you uh but not
everyone then i will still talk about it
a little bit and then we will go to the
conclusion
all right
the neue osnaprocatun is a regional
german newspaper
and in the newsroom there are many
different challenges there's a content
positioning what's shown on the first
page second page third page content
accessibility so paywalls everybody
knows them by now is it really worth
putting in a paywall at the sports
section of the newspaper or not
uh profitability of course is it's
running profitable
uh
our newspaper and the content creation
what's actually shown to to the readers
because the content is of course the
most important part of the newspaper
and that's also what we will focus about
in this talk um
content is like i said center for profit
and understanding reader preferences is
challenging what does
the readers really want to read
and
we have in the newsrooms
people working with a lot of experience
with a lot of subject matter knowledge
who know how to run a newspaper or it
wouldn't be there anymore and the
question is can we improve their
understanding
of reader's interest using natural
language processing
and can we help them make more
data-driven decisions
reader preferences is quite the broad
term there are many different ways we
can describe reader preferences we have
of course on-site tracking
for our different articles in the
newspaper and we have
metrics like the number of visits a
click-through rate
then metrics of engagement do people
comment do people like retweet a retweet
and so on
and we have the dwell time so how long
are people actually reading my article
and spending on this on the page
and we will use the dwell time
as our proxy for reader preferences
because we say okay
just clicking on the headline and then
going again is maybe not the best proxy
for interest in the
topic and in the content of the article
so dwell time is our dependent variable
and well time has of course again many
different effects on it we have the
article content
uh that is important for for dwell time
but or also the
length of the article it's quite obvious
the longer the article the longer the
expected dwell time will be
the sections of the newspaper connected
probably with the length so we have
many different influences on dwell time
and of course the
major outside influences for dwell time
so when you are reading an online
newspaper article an online article
there are everything else happening
around you and there will be a lot of
reasons why you stop reading in between
or
not continue or
and so on so
there are different impacts on our dwell
time i will now present the data we had
from the knots we had more than 36 08
articles
ranging from november 2019 to september
2020
more than 12 different sections in the
newspaper
and we don't have the
specific
reading time for every user for every
article but we have aggregated data so
we have an average dwell time per
article
for
in in our
of the newspaper
and we the question is can we
use our text the different section the
text length to model our
our expected well time and better
understand why readers are
reading for the amount of time they are
reading
below here you can see
just ahead of our data set basics
and
let's get to the nlp methods the core
problem that we are trying to solve is
that computers only understand numbers
statistical models only understand
numbers so the nlp must somehow try to
quantify the text we have and there are
many different ways we could quantify it
uh the
first versions i guess are the
vectorization approaches back of words
tf idf
which basically are counting words
creating dictionaries of words and
then use them as features in our in our
models
then we have the word embeddings who try
to
better grasp the the context of a word a
bit
the word to fast texts getting
some connections of the words with the
words around them the deep learning
approaches came afterwards through
different
versions and flavors of neural networks
who recurrent cnn lstms who all
try to incorporate even more context of
these different sentences into them so
trying not to understand or quantify one
single word but
the word in context around
the whole sentence
and then we have the transformer
architecture
which
brought it on a
more sophisticated level again and
uh
using the transfer learning
approaches
specifically with bear two is based on
this
transformer architecture
with what we will be using
for our modeling
and our
modeling of reader preferences
transfer learning leverage the
amount of work and resources that
other companies already used to train
the
natural language models here i got a
screenshot from jay alamer from his blog
article the illustrator transformer if
you haven't read that article yet i can
highly recommend you teachers great
articles with
animations
and
we also made a video about this article
he does great work explaining the whole
transformer architecture
and the ideas that we have
a large amount of text data and
we
estimate our model on
the me supervised learning step here
for example
predicting the next word in a sentence
and using these pre-trained models we
can then save them
and they graciously provide them for us
to to use and
then in the second step use this
pre-trained model as a basis for our
supervised training tasks so here
in this example it's a classification of
spam versus not spam
for our task we will use the
um
of course there is a dwell time so a
metric variable is our dependent
variable and
so use the basic pre-trained bird model
add layers on top of it
to get to our specific task and then
drastically cut down on training time
and leverage the amount of work that was
already put in by trading the date on a
large corpus
here again i have a short table about
the different methodizers talked about
and in general we can see that the more
sophisticated
methods the higher resource requirement
we have but the better the predictive
performance gets
but the
interpretability suffers enormously as
soon as we go back from away from the
simple
back of words models interpreting
why we got specific predictions gets
quite hard
and let's see what we can do and what if
the content really mattered
for our
task for our dwell time
and
here again we have the
setup we have our article text the
length the section and we want to
estimate some machine learning model to
understand our average
dwell time
and we have to manage our expectations a
bit we are trying to model human
behavior so we will not get
99.9
accuracy like when we classify some
mnist data or
something we have aggregated data per
article so when we can explain maybe 50
60 percent of the total variance in our
in our data set that will already be
a good result for human behavior like i
explained the there are a lot of outside
influences
that we just will not be able to account
for with the statistical model
like i said we will use a pre-trained
german bird model
add some additional layers for fine
tuning on top of this linears and drop
out layers
real leaky rail layers and
have a standard train eval test data
split
trends for a day on a gpu on
i've explained variants in our total
variants in our data set separated by
the different sections of the newspaper
and we can see that
we have quite the heterogeneous results
in our data set we have
sections like the good to know section
or the culture section of our newspaper
where we can almost explain nothing with
our text content we get a
model fit of below five percent around
five percent where we have other
sections of our
newspaper northwest failure lower saxony
where we have
45 50 55 percent uh
r squared so we are able to explain
the and model the the expected dwell
time of of readers in our sections
to a
reasonable amount
like i said before
the longer the article the longer the
expected dwell time and when you
talk with the people with subject matter
knowledge and to say well i'm great at
the sports section but it's a culture
section i'm not good they will ask you
okay our sports section is always quite
short that you are better there it's not
surprisingly was that bird model even
worse it i could tell told you that you
are
how long the people are reading my
sports sections
without the
work so the question is can we account
for that somehow specifically and
isolate the
effects and the contribution of our text
content
on our expected dwell time
and the idea is that we will
use a two-step approach for our modeling
we will estimate a gum model
without the text so we will remove our
remove the text content from our
modeling
and just use the section and the
article length to get the first estimate
of our average dwell time
and see what can we already explain just
using
the section and the article lengths
and we can see that
for
some areas we are already quite getting
quite a good model fit by just using
these two metrics no
nlp transformation no fighting whispered
and so on
and tokenization and everything but for
the austrisland region
part of our newspaper for the economy we
already get
25 30 percent sports action too
so
we get quite a large
model fit already for
for these sections of our newspaper
while for the northwest failure lower
saxony
where we had around 45 50 55 range of
our
r squared we don't get this much
explainability
and then in the second step
we will use the residuals from our first
model here we have our first model
getting our expected trail time
and we will then use this
residuals in our bird model so we take
the text we take our word normally what
i talked about the pre-trained and so on
and then
see what we can
what what's the isolated effect of our
text data
and
here we can see that for the different
sections of our newspaper the text
contents matters to a different degree
for example in the northrend west
failure we can see more than half of our
explained variance actually comes from
the text content while in the economy
section
at least with the model we are using
here we couldn't really identify a
contribution from the text content of
the articles same goes for sport like a
large amount of our explained variance
simply comes from the different sections
and the different lengths of the
articles
for modeling our our expected dwell time
and let's get to the explainable ai part
because it's really important to know
what your model actually learned
there are great methods out there
i will use shep as an example here
that help you understand what your black
box is doing there are
again and again embarrassing cases for
picture analysis where they are learning
that horses have a stamp of horse text
on the lower corner or
the they are not learning how a disease
covet lung looks like but that's a
person is laying down when he's sick and
not standing so it's important to have a
look at the explainable ai part of your
model and the same goes for
for nlp
and
we will enlighten the black box using
the chevrolet values approach
chevrolet values
have have their foundation in game
series so it has a theoretical
foundation it's a model agnostic method
so it can be applied for nlp it can be
applied for image
recognition for standard regression um
it identifies the contribution of
specific input values on the created
prediction so as long as you have a
model with a predict function and inputs
you can apply and use the shareplay
values to better understand what your
model has learned and what are the
different
contributions the
variables have
for the model
here you can see two examples from the
github package
and
you can see the
black box
where we have our output of our
prediction
with 0.4
and you have the different input
variables here h6 bp bmi
some base rate of 0.1 and using the
shapley values approach we can see okay
from our total prediction 0.4
our age
had a plus 0.4 contribution to that
value but the
female part at a minus 0.3
bp 100 180 has plus one and so on so it
is a
total predicted value is decomposed into
the different inputs
we had
and on the right hand side you can see
an example from the from an image
classification problem where you can see
what part of the image the model used to
make the decision
whether it's a bird or not
and
for our approach we had the two steps we
have our gum model
which is already
easily interpretable we have parameter
that we can read off we have splines to
interpret and so on so that's not a
case where bird is really necessary
because we can directly interpret sorry
but where sharp is really necessary
because we can directly interpret it
here for example i have an article
which had an average dwell time of 135
seconds
the gun model predicted 178 so we
overestimated our
dwell time for this article
have our residual of minus 43
and then adding our black box bird on
top of it but gives us a prediction of
-35 so we are getting much closer to the
true predicted
to the true observed
dwell time
and the question is why what part of the
article was important what contributed
to a longer dwell time what contributed
to a shorter rail time and using the
shep package and some fiddling around
until the code works and getting
everything
wrapped up in the chevrolet package
we get our
article text
and we can see the red areas
are text that is
associated with an increased dwell time
so that is text that increases our
expected dwell time according to our
model why the blue text is text that
reduces our expected dwell time
and we can see
that
the
first the blue part
is in the majority we can see the values
above that
in the end gives us our minus 35
prediction for our value
and we can see that
the company's history it's a german tax
now but that
is not really contributing to an
increase in our dwell time on this
article while that the company is also
training people and they are training
people from different
areas of expertise and they give
everyone a chance and for 100 years they
are great for their employees and so on
and so on that's
context that our model learned increases
the dwell time and the people want to to
read and
[Music]
make them stay at our newspaper and
increase their expected real time so
at the conclusion we can say that yes
nlp definitely adds a benefit to our
classical approach we can isolate the
effects
of
our text and use shablee values to
identify what part of the text
contributed to
staying longer or shorter in our in our
text in our article
we saw that the
benefit of text content varied greatly
between different sections so we had
sections in our newspaper where the text
lengths
and the section itself already explained
most of what our model was able to to
learn
and the methods i
uh
i've shown here are all generals so
if we had more fine grained
user data or different tasks like is the
paywall
worth it or not we can
apply these
method to methods too to
better understand that and improve our
predictive
modeling
special thanks goes to the
ricker who
was the student who wrote the master
thesis about that topic she is now doing
her phd here at in berlin at the
humboldt university
professor dr udo han who was a
professor at the friday school in
university of inner where she studied
and
stephen wagner who
is our lead data scientist at inwt
who also
supported her master's thesis
all right thank you for your attention
[Applause]
okay uh thank you for the interesting
talk we have a ton of questions so um
yeah i think we should just start
the most the best question is
how did you overcome the token input
length of birth
we stayed with the first 512 tokens so
for the newspaper
i guess it's not as bad as when you have
other tasks because
just using the first 512
tokens is quite limiting of course
but for
modeling at real time for an article i
guess it's not
as bad as when you try to
do
some other classification task or
whatever so
having
yes so we just stayed with it
okay next one i can imagine that a
traveling time distribution squad sku
have you tried using median trail time
instead of mean
no we had the data
aggregated from our customers so we
didn't have the specific
time and i
if i recall correctly the customer also
cleaned the data a bit and already they
know know their data better than than we
do they are the experts and so we had
the average dwell time per article given
as a dependent variable
okay um what about seasonal effects of
reader preferences
we haven't add any seasonal
part into our model as you saw
it's
difficult how you would set that up in
an
lp model
so
you could maybe try add it to the when
we had the two-step approach with the
gum you are more flexible so you could
check if that that you can come in
compar incorporate it into the first
model
um yes i guess that would be an idea to
tackle that question
okay
what is the baseline performance of a
simple model
i don't have that for you right now
sorry maybe uh
i think we have it we have tried many
different models and there's a whole
master thesis about different model
approaches and everything so just
contact me
via discord and i can get that to you
how would a model that takes only the
sections will perform
only the sections without the article
length
i think this isn't a direction of the
screwness of the distribution or to
i don't know i'm not sure how that would
perform i would assume that it will
perform worse than the one with section
plus article length but i can tell you
uh how good that would already fit
what is your opinion about using average
trail time on the impact on the quality
and the variety of the content yeah
could you repeat it so yeah what is the
what is your opinion about using average
trial time on the impact
uh on the quality and the variety of
content
so basically
what i understand is the relation
between
drill time and quality of content
i would assume the higher the quality
the longer the drill time but
i'm
sorry maybe i don't get the question
right now and we can talk about it after
the
i'm sorry i'm not sure
how was the distribution of the section
data is the unbalance explaining your
difference in fit
we
when you saw
we had 12 different sections here and we
basically have have an other section and
also
we
grouped with like there were i guess 50
or more different sections in our data
and we try to balance the group by
putting them in
reasonable content
buckets
okay
is it correct that you're not trying to
predict the trail time for a specific
user but rather the mean trail time for
an article if yes why is that
um because that's the data we are
available is the short answer
having
user specific data is always a privacy
concern too so having some aggregated
data kind of alleviates that problem too
so having
your specific browser history is always
critical and if it's
it's also nothing that's easily
distributed or anything so we had that
data available
um have you tried modeling your user
base to identify groups of similarity
behave people i think that's that's
already answered we didn't have the user
base um
have you tried using embedding so
simpler or linear models
um yes there were we have tried
different models we also had
for our for the explainable ai part with
chap wasn't easy to get working and we
also tried
using
word-to-web embeddings plus an xg boost
model to then use shareplay values and
map it back onto the words
it's
not because we have
the
vector representation of the embedding
and the shapley values gets us a
contribution
basically of
the 512 or whatever embedding
dimensions calculating it all back on a
per word level is quite difficult so we
tried different things out but what i'm
presenting you here had
the best results
okay um
next one why did the client choose
average trail time as a target
i i can't answer that
sorry no
do you think it's uh it was a good shot
i think it's okay and having an average
is a reasonable
assumption for
for modeling yes the median is more
robust
and
but
they are subject they are the expert of
their data they know what they are doing
they are doing it for
many years so
at least i assume that that was a
good choice and i trust uh in in that
and yes
man a lot of questions
you're also interested in the talk maybe
have different sections significant
different length that can influence the
results for correlation
yes different
sections have different lengths so
that's why we did the
length model in front of it um maybe i
didn't understand the question correctly
but
i guess
i i believe uh is is basically um
are you fitting
with your trail time basically the
length after of the article that's what
i what i understand from the
from the question you know like is your
is your model effectively counting words
instead of predicting at at time
there are
we we have our two models and one model
is
getting the length and estimate getting
an estimate of the dwell time
with the bird
model
bird incorporates the text length if the
article is shorter than 512 tokens then
we got the filler tokens at the end and
maybe bird is deriving
some part of understanding of text
lengths into
the modeling too
i'm not sure if that already is a
sufficient answer to the question but
maybe if you are in the room or just
come to me after the talk
uh or
we can chat via discord okay and then i
have more questions but one last one um
and short answer please how uh how has
your model been applied to receive to
preserve the predictions
um
what was the added value to the
newspaper um the model is not yet in
production at the newspaper it's like i
said we had master thesis and
we have now advanced and
i guess
changed it a bit and added more content
to it
but it's not yet in production at the
newspaper so it's more of a proof of
concept what can be done and
what can we do and learn using these
methods
okay thanks for the talk thanks for
taking the time for all the questions
and give it up for the birthday
[Applause]